[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
leading the industry in direct trace
elemental analysis of seawater with
nexion icp ms
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by perkin elmer to learn more visit
perkinelmer.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
kenneth ong principal inorganic product
specialist perkin elmer singapore
kenneth you may now begin your
presentation
good day everyone before i begin i would
like to thank dr eve cookrabbs icpms
product manager and dr c lee yan senior
application scientist of perkin elements
for allowing me to share their works
with you
the materials was first presented on
spectroscopy forums
today we will be talking about how our
technologies can help to carry out
direct trace elementals analysis of sea
waters
and look at some of the works done by dr
singh
now about 71 percent of earth's surface
is water and of this 71
of earth surface water about 97 percent
are covered by the ocean
you probably also know that entire
populations obtain 25
of the proteins we consumed from the
oceans and that is about 21 trillion
dollars in food supplies
the oceans on tops of providing us food
is where millions of people rely on
fishing to make their living
you may ask with so many things like
plastic microplastic
organic pollutants and other harmful
things in our oceans
why would we be concerned with elements
contaminants that are found naturally
with increased human activities the rate
at which these elemental contaminants
being introduced to the environment has
significantly increased
source of these elemental pollutions
must be identified so that we can reduce
or eliminate the introductions into the
oceans to create a safe living grounds
to support the marine life
elements introduced into the
environments are
non-biodegradable
they may change in their molecular form
they could become less toxic but they
can also become more toxic and more
available for upticks by plants and
marine life
as such they are more persistent to
remains in the environment for longer
terms compared to organic contaminants
there have been so many cases that the
release of methods into the environments
have led to disastrous consequences for
both biomes and the ecosystem
such as deliberates or accidental
release of industrial
pollution or the spillage during an
accident on the sea
while most countries followed who in
monitoring the coastal waters
some have their heavy metals monitoring
programs and regulation specifications
for enforcement
two examples of these programs are the
malaysians marine waters quality
standards and the australians and new
zealand environment and conservation
council water guidelines
there are a few challenges that needs to
be addressed in the analysis of sea
waters
sea water samples are known to have high
total dissolved solids and if you have
lots of samples for testing you would
like to be able to reduce downtimes and
routines maintenance to in order to
maximize your productivity
the complex natures of the sea water
samples present another challenge
the techniques that we use to correct
for this polyatomic interference from
the plasma gas and the major components
of the sea waters matrix
will affect the accuracies of our result
and this must be addressed
now the longer you analyze the sea
waters you are going to get more sort
into your systems and that could choke
up your rvs
and cause signals drift
as important as speed of analysis
you you would also want to have longer
stability despite the complexness
of the matrix
so you did like to have some features
that will help to improve and ensure
long-term stability
we will be discussing on how we address
these challenges and needs
icpms has long been the instruments of
choice for trace
elemental analysis
there are different types of icpms
such as the simple
quotable icpms without a cell
to correct for polyatomic interference
so you really have to rely on
inter-elements corrections to get the
right result
or you can have a single quartz
analyzers with the cell
to remove polyatomic interference
through either collisions are the
reactions
we can also have
um
or use a triple quartz instruments which
are able to filter analytes before they
enter the cell
and finally there are multi quadrupole
icpms that has the capability beyond
triple quad systems
of having active controls over the
reactions in the cell
as well as an additional quarter pole
before the first analyzer quality that
replaces
conventional land systems and we'll look
into that a bit more in the details
later
to show the difference of a quartable
systems versus a multi-global systems
we'll look at nixon's platform as an
example
both the nexons have an additional
q0
the benefits of this design is that it
allows ions to be diffracted at the 90
degrees
into the downstream optics while the
neutral species and the photons will
continue
on straight paths into vacuums without
depositing on the surface
with the helps of a hyperschema cones
there are no other lenses in the designs
that will require frequency cleaning as
such
mixtures practically require no
cleanings beyond the cones
this is very important for heavy metric
samples analysis such as seawater
applications
the q0 can applies with a fixed or a
scanning voltage in synchronized with
the quadrupole
with a fixed voltage you can create a
mass filtering only masses within 16
atomic mass units of the targeted mass
will be allowed to pass through into
downstream optics
again this mass range trimming
trimming capabilities provide additional
advantage in complex matrix analysis
if you compare the objects beyond the q0
you will see that in the next in the
case of the nexon's 1000 and 2000 there
is a missing of q1 before the cell well
there is a q1
in a triple quartz of nixon 5000
multi-corporal icp ms
the q1 not only
acts as an additional filters it allows
mass shifting operations to be carried
out in a more precise manner
what may not be obvious to you is
q2
the quadruple in the cell is capable of
rejecting high amounts of low masses
with respect to the targeted mass
so that
when reactions class curve products form
the changes of interference at higher
masses are greatly reduced
these features is
especially useful for those corporal
systems which
don't have an additional q1 before the
cell
to illustrate the differences between
triple quad
icpms and multi-quartable systems we
will look at what is
happening inside a conventional triple
quartz in the next slide
a conventional triple quadruple ice cpms
have two stages of mass resolutions on
q1
and q3
in these systems there is typically a
lens system which is used to focus the
ion beams
from there the amp beams pass through
to the first transmissions analyzer
quadrupole for the first stage of mass
resolution
in the msms on mass or the mass shift
mode
only months of interest is allowed to
proceed and transmit into the cell
all other ions at different masses are
rejected by q1
in this example here
mass 52 are transmitted to
through q1
while other muscles such as argon faulty
and carbon 12 ions are rejected
when mass 52 enter the cell the ions are
subjected to reactions for the best
interference removal so in this case
argon carbons with mass 52 reach the
cell and start reacting with the ammonia
the cell gas that we commonly use
they either transfer the charge to
ammonia or dissociate into argon and
carbon ions
although the ions in the cells are well
characterized
the cell with higher order of multiple
rod
such as hexapoles or octopus are passive
cell
its only functions is to act as an ion
guide to transmit ion through the cells
and therefore offer no mass resolution
functionality
to understand why this is so important
in the above examples of pure ammonia
gas that was added to the cells to
remove argon-carbon interference from
chromium at mass 52
as i explained
earlier
unfortunately
additional interference can form from
the reactions byproducts
in this case the reactive ammonia gas
form cluster at mass 52
which will not be separated in the cells
or the subsequence q3 analyzer
quadrupole
in this product scan mode analysis where
we have intentionally turned off the
active band pass in the cell
even when q1 only allows ion of mass 52
to enter the cell
the ammonia was introduced to the cell
directly you could see new classical
ions were forming at mass 18 19 35 and
52
this produced around 5 000 cows at mass
52 as observed
which is a combined thickness of
chromium
purities in methanol
the samples that we analyze
and ammonia cluster which leads to false
positive in a result in a passive cell
in the multi-qualified cpms as in the
case of an exon
54 stages of active resolutions
two additional procedures of mass
resolutions are the quadrupole before
the q1
which is the q0
it replaced the traditional land systems
the other additional resolutions which
is not obvious to most people's
however is of problems importance is in
the q2
which is the active reaction cell
the
chlorophyll ion diffractors beside
turning the ions 90 degrees into the
downstream optics
it also trim downs the ions
with masses that are different from the
targeted analyte mass
and totally eliminates uncharged ions
back to the q1 filters
as with the traditional triple
quadrupole system
it allows only the mass of interest to
proceed to the cell while all other ions
are rejected
however the real difference comes in
with an active
proposed cell
in the nixons we call this the universal
cell with dynamic band pass
tuning
the cell is a true critical
cell and it provides an additional stage
of mass resolution
and actively destabilizes and
rejects reactions by products
before
they have
a chance to react with gas against
impurities
thereby prevents false count at targeted
mass of interest
in the nexion's eye cpms with the
capability of setting dynamic band pass
functionality in the cell we can see
that all previous observed pick from
ammonia and against classical at mars
18s and 35s are removed
leaving a clean analyze sickness at mass
52
which is around 500 cows per second and
that is corresponding to the real
chromium impurity in december
this is a comparison of a product scan
mode in exam 5 thousands the pictures on
the top is a scan where we have turned
the band pass tuning in the universal
cell off and we're looking for veneniums
in an ultra pure slot
you can see that we are picking up
about 100 counts of false finance
in the pictures on the bottom we have
turned on the band pass settings just as
with earlier slide
cluster at low mass around 35
were rejected by q2
the cell actively prevents byproducts
from forming
and we are seeing a much lower
count at mass 51.
this is so important
for trace matters determinations of sea
waters
only icpms with band pass will give you
a true detection of chromium and
vanadium at lower levels where having a
q1 in front of a passive cell isn't
enough
so to speak the performance of nixon
1000 or the 2000s with ammonia reaction
mode in veneniums and chromium
determinations at mass 51 and 52
is much more superior than an icpms
triple quad systems with a passive cell
now that we know how to take care of
polyethylene interference let's move
back a step and look at how we can
handle the high dissolved salt contents
in sea waters analysis of seawaters can
add a great deal to any
lag in terms of the times it takes to
perform it
and the increased cost of consumables
the high sub content not only increase
the maintenance needs it results in
plasma loading effects and may suppress
the ionizations of analytes with high
ionization potential such as mercury
arsenic and selenium
we could do this with an all metric
solutions ems systems
in the nexon which is a simple
aerosol dilution
capable up to 12 times dilution
now maybe a lot of you are not aware we
have this capability of adding dilutions
gas since the iran's era
the ams not only just simplified sample
preparations
with the sub contents reduced we could
reduce depositions on the interface
and also effect a more
efficient ionization
thereby generating higher quality data
for elements such as arsenic seleniums
and mercury
however it should be notes that the gas
dilutions is universally applies to all
elements
and lights and measures matrix or
aligned
for coastal water analysis we may not
only be interested in trace top 6
elements but are also interested in
major elements
since the nexion cell is a true
quartable pole cell
it can affect a selective attenuation
the dynamic range of the detector is
increased to more than 12 orders of
magnitudes
without causing damage to the detectors
and impacts on their usage life
the selective attenuations or the
extended dynamic range can be extremely
useful for coastal waters and is unique
to
quadrupole-based cell
analyzing both high and low
concentrations of analytes within a
singles analysis run
using the ams and the edr or external
range together offer great deals of
flexibility in analysis of sea waters
you can see in this image we have a scan
of a 100 ppm of sodium
and magnesium
the blue thickness is without any
dilutions signals are saturated for both
sodium and magnesium
for the same solutions we can effects
and aerosol dilutions using the ams
with these the thickness of sodium
and magnesium are reduced as shown by
the red lines
since ems affects a universe's dilution
for the green signals we have applied
edr selectively on sodium
and on top of using the ams
as you can see the thickness at mass
23 decrease
but since the edr
was not applied to magnesium at mass 24
its sickness remains unaffected just as
with the red lines so with the
combinations of gas
solutions and equipment pole cell
you have the flexibility of analyzing
measures and trains and lights in sea
waters within the same
meters
dilution is not the only way we can
reduce the depositions on the cones
if we can keep the samples loading as
short as possible as it is required only
during analysis
we will be able to prolong the intervals
for the needs to clean the cones
one way of achieving this is by mean of
a flow injection technique
not only does it help to shorten the
exposures of cones to start build up it
can enhance the sample throughputs
as you can see
from
the two samples uptakes and analysis
time charge on the left the rig
thickness is with a conventional
[Music]
auto sampler's loadings the total
exposures times of the cones to the sort
loadings from uptakes to wash down could
be as long as seven to eight minutes
where else with the flow injections such
as the high throughput systems or the
hts from turkey armors we could
potentially cut the exposures times to a
short of 2 minutes with the same length
of times needed for analysis by icp ms
if you look at the signal charge on the
top right
the samples draw up quickly by means of
a vacuum
into the plasma
in as short as nine seconds from the
points the probes move into the samples
the sickness
is stable in the plasma much faster and
potentially we could start the icpms
analysis after about 12 seconds from
products into the sample valves
what the hts does is it reduce the
residence times of the samples in the
plasma
the ams also allows for online dilutions
of internal standards
on top of reducing maintenance frequency
and dramatically reduce
samples run times
hence improved samples throughput
the nexion's instrument supports the
perky elmer's high throughput systems or
hts as well as all full range of esi
file systems and syntax express system
now that we have an idea of tackling the
biggest challenges in analyzing sea
waters we are ready to do some actual
analysis now sea waters has a
standardized of around three to five
percent and it contains small amounts of
other inorganics and organic materials
so let's recaps there are two main
aspects of sea water samples that mix
analysis with ic pms challenging
firstly sea waters sea waters contains
high amounts of sodium
chloride magnesium calcium sulfates etc
and will have interference on ic pms
analysis
secondly the trace elements that we are
analyzing the heavies methods
can be of very low concentrations
now the high dissolved salts will have
matrix effects
which leads to severe sickness
suppressions or enhancements
and of course long-term stability
sickness instability due to salt and
carbon deposit on interface
it definitely will have spectra or
polyethylene interference
generated by the plasma based ions like
argons carbons and oxygens with the salt
which will overlap with targeted
analytes for example
um argon chloride and calcium chloride
on arsenic
argon
with the sodium at mass 63 that will be
copper and argon with magnesium on zinc
at mass 64
and
chlorine with the oxygens
on mass 51 and of course argon with
carbons on chromiums
now the concentrations of trace elements
are in a range of ppb down to ppt levels
now as mentioned the nexion platforms
are equipped with universal cell
technologies and the nixons can operate
in standards mode without the use of any
cell gas
in collisions or ked modes using neutral
gases such as
helium and reaction smoke with dynamic
band pass tuning using a varieties of
reactive gases
now with the nixon 5000 multi quadruple
icpms there are two basic processors
msms and mast shift mode
to achieve interference free analysis
with the on
msms mode analytes ions and interfering
ions with the same mass are selected by
q1
once enter q2
the interference start reacts with the
the cell gas and are rejected
and the enlightened ions are analyzed in
q3
example of such modes of analysis is in
the determinations of chromium where
calcium carbons and all the argan
carbons are removed
now in the
mass shift modes operations the
interference remains unreacted while the
analyzed ions react with the cell gas in
q2
to form higher mass ions
the q3 will scan at higher mass where
the analytes has moved to while the
interference are rejected
example of such move such of analysis is
in the determinations of arsenic
75
in the presence of argon chloride where
arsenic ions react with oxygen cell gas
to form
arsenic oxide at mass
91
there are a few approaches in sea water
sample preparations for icpms analysis
first approach is a simple offline
dilution
and we can perform manually or using
standalone automated equipments
while it requires additional costs for
dedicated equipment it is still laborers
and will have high risk of contaminating
the samples
once the advance will be using an inline
dilution such as the use of breakfast
from esi of course this add on
additional cost
the next approach is with sample
pre-concentrations using a columns to
remove the matrix components
while retaining the pre-concentrated
analytes of interest which will be
backwashed by a buffer solution
into the icpms for analysis
this can be done manually or with the
elegance equipments like the c-files
the advantage of this approach is
obvious
however it adds on additional cost to
instruments investment
it is not an easy approach as you need
to really take care of the columns
preparing the buffer that must be
meta-free
and it lengthens the sample to sample
analysis time with loading
pre-concentrating
and back washing step
now our approach
will be using a regular samples
introduction systems with no manual
dilutions nor expensive accessory
it combines the liquid dilutions
with the internal standards
and air shows through the all metrics
system
not only does this approach doable with
expensive accessory there are no
additional labor steps
no steep learning curve or new samples
handling accessory and most importantly
reduce the possibility of contaminating
the samples
during
handling
we apply a 2 4 gas dilutions by
all matrix solutions and a 5 4 liquid
dilutions through the internal standards
the ems argon gas is introduced to the
nets of the spray chambers where it
meets with the primary aerosols thus
reducing the amount of analytes into the
plasma which practically dilutes the
samples
the liquid dilution is achieved by using
a larger id pump tubing for the internal
standard solutions introductions
while a smaller ids for the samples two
effects a one is to find dilutions on
the samples
to reduce the samples loads to the
plasma
high triple system is used and it
delivers the samples to the plasma only
during the data acquisition stage and
diverts the samples to the waste for the
rest of the run
by means of a vacuum
it draws and diverts the samples through
the samples loop in a very short times
and perform wash procedures more
efficiently and effectively than
conventional prosthetic plant-based
introduction system
now in this case the hts is used in line
with a s20
auto sampler
we will be using the metric match
approach and that will be standard
additions in the syngistic software for
the calibration standards were prepared
in three percent ultra clean sodium
chloride from the esi
and acidified to one percent nitric acid
the mercury
was calculated in a low range of 0.01 to
10 ppb
and the length of the elements were
calibrated in a range of 0.1 to 100 ppb
three seawater crms were used for method
validations where the nas 7
is originated from open sea
waters
class 6 and the
mx-014 are from coastal and near shore
waters
the certified values of these crms were
shown on this slide the nuts and cars
seawater crms are from the national
research councils canada
while there is no reference for selenium
it is still useful for method
validations
and some elements such as zinc and ions
are at such low levels would really need
a clean environment to prevent cross
contamination
dmx-014 is a reference from the national
measurements institute it is actually a
fortified sea waters and elements are in
a range of one to five ppb mostly
this range is more realistic to be
achieved in most lab without a clean
room environment
list in these tables are the instrument
settings
and parameters
we use a pfa microflow nebulizer as
compared to a glass nebulizer pfa has a
slight advantage of low memory effects
the spray chambers come with an
ams matrix port for us to
effects the elso dilutions
the parastatic pump tubing for the
carrier was orange rate with 0.19 mm id
and the priceline palm tubings for the
internet standards was
orange yellow with 0.51 mm id
the error so rather the ams gas was
optimized for
half the intensity of indiums in
standards mode
3 cell gases were used oxygen ammonias
and heliums
this table leaves the masses the mode of
analysis for nexon 5000 and the gas
profiles used for each analyte
just to use titaniums
as an example in the nixon 2000
we are using titaniums at mass for the
egg using helium gas to remove potential
polyatomic interference from so and poh
while using iec connections for calcium
since helium does not remove the calcium
in the case of the nexon 5000 we have
the advantage of mass shift mode and
that is what i meant by the mode of
analysis
and yes titanium was analyzed using
ammonia classical at mass 131
moving it away from the
mass for the interference such as the
poh so and calcium
now one important point that i want to
highlight is the cone cleanliness
a lot of times we want the cones to be
as clean as possible for the start of
sample analysis
however for sea water applications we
would like to conditions the cones
the cones will be well conditioned if we
see a stabilized thickness of internal
standard elements and this takes about
10 to 20 minutes of continued
aspirations of the sea waters of the
three percent sodium chloride
once the cones are conditions we can
proceed to do the calibration
shown here are some calibration curve on
nexion 5 thousands
on the top left here is the titanium
measured with a mass shift ammonia
classical techniques
and on the right is the arsenics
again using mass shift with oxygens
now vitamins and the coppers are
measured on the
mass ms ms mode with ammonia band pass
settings for vanadium to prevent site
reactions as we discussed earlier
and since copper levels is typically not
very low we could do this easily in the
collision mode
the accuracy was verified by the
recovery of elements with the certified
values in the sea waters crms
the recovery were within 10
for the analyte certified in open sea
waters crm nest seven using the nixon
5000
and the recoveries also within 10
percent were achieved for moons and
likes in the coastal
sea waters crm the cast 6 and the mx-014
using
the nexon 2000 icbms
and the
arsenics and mercury is falling
slightly beyond the 10 percent but still
within the 20 percent accuracy
since there are few elements without
certified values for the nest and cats
a spud recovery test was used to
validate the methods for those elements
where sea waters were spiked with
elemental standards
and run as a samples now a good recovery
within
ten percent were obtained for all metric
spike standards on the nexion 5000
system
now obtaining a good recovery is not
enough as with any environmental
monitoring protocol we need to ensure
that the method has a detection limit
capable of meeting or exceeding the
specifications limit set by the
regulatory bodies
all the method detection limits fulfills
the detections requirements by the two
seawaters monitoring programs mentioned
before from the australian new zealand's
as well as simulations
those program specifications are in the
green bars
in fact meta detection mix were in a
single digits ppt to sub ppt levels for
most
elements there are few elements that
will at double digits levels but they
are commonly present in
regular
laboratories environments such as the
aluminium iron nickel copper and zinc
now if you look at the orange bar those
are the detection limits for the 5 000
they are much much
lower compared to the
light purples that is from the nexion
2000
as important as accuracy and detection
limits long-term stability is a need and
desirable for seawater's analysis
for this the sea water samples were
measured repeatedly over a period of 10
hours
and the ccv's recovery will monitor over
this period to check for stability
as shown in this figure there was no
apparent trend throughout the run
demonstrating the validity of
calibrations
over the whole sample run and all the
ccv or continuous calibration
verifications recovery were found to be
within 20
of the originals reading
this definitely will help
high triple laboratories in terms of
overall efficiency and productivity by
avoiding having to re-run
the calibration standards
so that you spend more time doing your
analysis rather than doing calibrations
now come to the conclusions of our
discussions a simple direct analysis of
trace elements in sea water samples
using nixon 2000 and 5000 icpms can be
carried out
with the ams and by means of an internal
standard dilutions
the high throughput systems not only
speed up the analysis
throughputs it reduce the exposures of
cones from salt
the exceptional detections limits
accuracy and long-term stability provide
a strong evidence on the superior
interference removal capability and
outstanding sensitivity after nexione
of course comparing the nexium platforms
nixon 5000 has the advantage in
sensitivity and interference removal
capability
the results that dr singh obtains proof
that we are leading the industry in the
direct trace elemental analysis of sea
waters
with this i thank you for your attention
and have a smooth sealing in your
seawater analysis
thank you kenneth for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
which type of icp ms is recommended for
seawater analysis and why
okay um that's a very broad but very
good questions yeah so the things about
sea waters we have discussed is that
it contains high dissolved uh solids so
you need uh you need icpms that have the
robustness to actually handles the
matrixes
now the second thing is that a lot a lot
of ic cameras are very concerned with
drifting
so you must actually have a systems that
are able to take care of sort build up
such that it does not clog your
rfe so
the nexion as we mentioned actually have
a white oral fee so that will actually
helps to prevent
the rfe from clocking up and causing
signatories now of course with that we
are going to get in a lot of salt into
the icp ms uh the iron optics so then
you must actually have
an optics that is capable of uh removing
the uncharged particles uh as you get
into the
unoptic systems next is actually how we
are going to remove the interference
so of course uh i don't think anybody
would want to do with a single quartz is
without a cell technologies that is
probably something that i do and 30
years ago
so you probably want to go with the
systems that come with a cell uh to help
you to remove the
interference otherwise you really have
depends on mathematical formulas and you
need to do a lot of predictions and
assumptions
now back to the reactions of subject to
the cell we can actually use reactions
so we can actually use collision cell
and i think uh along the presentations
we have discussed that
so for collision cell we are going to
use
cases like helium
uh so there's no selectivity is actually
based on the surface of cross-sectional
areas
to remove the product atomic
interference
now if you go into a systems where in
the interference is as big as the
analyte then you are going to throw in
high flow of helium
and that will actually result in you
getting
very low
sensitivity so with the sea water
analysis as you see we have to do some
dilutions
and that is going to get your trace
toxic elements to be random levels
so the next best approach then is to use
a condition as a erection cell
using
ammonia gas for example
um that because of the selectivity it's
not going to reduce
your thickness of analytes and thereby
allowing to achieve much lower
detections capabilities
we also discuss on
uh using singers
quadrupole versus a
uh i won't got too much so we we did
mention that with the multi-quarter pole
systems or the icpms ms you have better
control of fractions and that certainly
would actually uh be uh
added advantage of icpms uh using
reaction cell
um so i i probably want to stop here
this is a very long uh questions to be
asked uh to answer so um
i will probably get in touch with these
customers to actually know
discuss further
okay thank you
next question
i have a i have an icp ms instrument
from another company
can i match the performance of nexion
2000 for seawater analysis
oh
yeah it depends on the types of icgms
they have so if you are looking at just
a collision systems that just mentions
that collisions sell if you want to
analyze
systems
where in your interference is as big as
your
analytics then you need to actually flow
a high uh
collision gas and that will actually
result in you having a lower sensitivity
so definitely with the 2000s now um you
you have the choice of three gas uh
channel so you can still make use of
helium gas and lines uh for example
elements that is high in concentrations
uh they have fewer interference uh
because you you you do not need that
kind of sensitivity
and for reactions most then you can
actually make use of uh gases such as
oxygens
or ammonia gas uh to help you to remove
the interference while actually
retaining the sensitivity of your
analytes so certainly i think with the
2000 it
would in
a way outperforms
a systems that only provide just a
collections mode
thank you
next question
for copper analysis you have showed
using helium mode
do we have any advantage in using
reaction mode
oh yes certainly as i mentioned
a while ago so it the coppers uh levels
in the sea waters especially in the near
shore sea water analysis the levels are
actually not low
so with that of course you can use um
healing modes to do your analysis but
when we are looking at uh
offshore sea waters where the corpus
levels that want to actually check for
are low levels then the reaction will
also have the advantage um
because now the interference of a copper
at 63 would be
sodium with a argon or it could be a
sodium with a calcium that's in
abundance and if you look at copper 63
aside 65 you will have interference
coming from sulfur and fossils which is
also abundance in seawater analysis
so with that we can use ammonia gas
we actually have to remove the uh
polyethylene interference
now we also discussed about 5000
now uh
what we can do is that we can make use
of again the ammonia gas
in this case not for the amount of gas
to react
the interference but to get the ammonia
gas in excess so we'll flow a high flow
of hormone against to react with copper
and move it to copper 60 side move it to
copper that will be
two cluster ammonia and that will be at
mass 97 so what we do is that q1 or
rather the first protopole
will focus in corpus 63
and that certainly we are going to focus
in
your sodium and argon
interference into the cell and in the
cell that will now flow in high amounts
of ammonia gas now if you know about
chemistry uh high flow of ammonias uh it
tends to form cluster with a lot of
matters and that's what we're going to
do we're going to get coppers to form
cluster with the ammoniums and morphed
the mass 97. so q3 will actually focus
uh mass 97 which is the ammonia cluster
whereas the sodiums and argons they are
not going to actually form cluster with
ammonia they are going to break off to
sodiums and organs and in that way we
are we are going to actually be able to
detect uh copper at a much cleaner mass
and certainly it allows us to detect at
a much lower levels
okay so that would be the advantage of
using reaction modes
thank you
all right thank you
next question
you show that the aerosol dilute
the sample two times and five times for
the liquid
can i just do a dilution with is by
changing the size of pump tubing
so is dilutions with the internet
standards
well certainly yeah so if you do not
actually want to use the aerosols the
ams system to do dilutions uh you can
actually change the
the pump tubings depending on the size
so basically a quick calculation will be
getting the
diameters
uh square of the diameters of your
internal standards over the square
diameters of your the pump tubing for
the samples
and that will be the uh
digestion factors that you will achieve
uh through the use of internal standard
studio dilutions now of course you need
to have a t-joint to actually join the
two
pump tubings out
yeah
all right and we will wrap up with that
question thank you kenneth do you have
any final comments for our audience
well yeah so if you do uh want to know
more informations about the sea waters
analysis solutions that we provide uh
feel free to reach out to the sales
representative in countries and will
definitely get you more answers to your
needs
thank you again kenneth for your time
today in your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor perkin elmer for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
or via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
boots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone and
goodbye
you